you
[Music]
okay it's my great pleasure to introduce
Danielson then I was a student in a PhD
candidate at Stanford he wasn't on the
first one and a half years ago I have
been collaborating with him for like
three years and completely different
topics
last time he visits does he was using
formal methods to verify machine
learning algorithms and today he's
showing his the progress amazing in
trying to learn assets over write to
have a new network that learns set hi
everybody thanks for coming today
I'll be showing you how to learn an
entire set solving algorithm from single
bit supervision and this is all joint
work with Leonardo and several others
back at Stanford so as most of you know
neural networks have beaten
state-of-the-art on many important
problems just in the last few years most
notably object recognition and speech
recognition but there have also been
major successes in diverse and I think
unexpected domains including machine
translation social network analysis
heuristics for board games like chess
and go even predicting properties of
molecules optimizing data center
efficiency and surprisingly even
learning high-performance indexing data
structures and yet we still know very
little about what neural networks can
and cannot do in this work we consider
the following question can a neural
network learned to perform precise
logical reasoning and more specifically
can a neural network learn to solve Sat
problems here's our set up we're going
to train a neural network as a
classifier on a data set of input-output
pairs where the input is a Sat problem P
and the output is a single bit
indicating whether or not P is
satisfiable at test time we're gonna
feed problems
into our trained model which we call
neuro set and it's going to predict as
it was trained to do whether the
problems are satisfiable or not as we'll
see later in the talk it's able to
predict with high accuracy and when it
does predicts that is viable we can
almost always decode an actual solution
a satisfying assignment from the
internal activations of the network and
we'll see how this works shortly
first some background on sat I think
most of you will be familiar with this
but just in case a propositional formula
can be represented as an and of ORS so
here's an example formula and not x1 or
x2 and not x2 or x1 some jargon x1 not
x1 x2 not x2 are all called literals and
c1 and c2 are both called clauses now a
formula is satisfiable if there exists a
satisfying assignment so the formula
above is satisfiable because there
exists the satisfying assignment
specifically the assignment that map's X
1 and X 2 both to true satisfies it
because the first Clause is satisfied
because X 2 is true and the second
clause is satisfied because X 1 is true
and thus at problem is given a formula
determine if it is satisfiable and if it
is find a satisfying assignment now our
goal is to train a neural network to
predict satisfiability and we're going
to talk about decoding solutions and
actually solving the problems later on
and there are two main design challenges
what problems do we train on and with
what kind of architecture let's talk
about training data first so the issue
is that some problem distributions might
be arbitrarily easy to classify based on
superficial properties but a network
that's trained on such a data set
probably will exploit those properties
and it won't generalize and won't really
have learned anything semantics about
Sat so we want to construct difficult
problems to force it to learn something
general to be more systematic about
exploring the Sat problem so we define a
distribution that we call SR of n over
problems such that the problems come in
pairs one unsettle in a single Clause
but otherwise have the same statistics
so the idea is that we will prevent no
simple superficial statistical analysis
we'll be able to distinguish between the
two and specifically to sample a pair of
problems from SR of n we keep sampling
random uniformly random clauses until
the problem is unsatisfiable at which
point we flip a single literal in the
final clause to make it sat and we
return the pair
before and after we flip that literal
now this distribution does not
guaranteed to be hard in any complexity
theoretic sense but it's intuitively
statistically hard for small values
event it's still easy for traditional
SAP solvers but it would be very hard
for a standard classifier now let's talk
about network architecture so we could
treat sad problems as character strings
we yeah as if it were R and K CNF as if
it is uniform random set we keep we
start with n variables and no clauses
will sample a random uniform clause on
the n variables and check call us that's
over to see if it's satisfiable if it's
satisfiable we do it again we keep
adding clauses like this sampling
reading pauses and adding them I'm sorry
that wasn't good the point is that doing
a little faster so we know that before
the last Clause is introduced the
problem is still satisfiable so we know
that flipping any literal in the last
Clause will preserve the model that was
satisfying previously so we know we can
recover a satisfiable instance by
flipping a literal in the final clause
yeah yeah start from going too fast
please anyone stop me at any time so
let's talk about network architecture we
could treat stat problems as character
strings and use standard sequence models
we saw that I wrote is that problem
above characters it's an ST standard
models can be applied but there are many
invariances that we want to enforce that
the logic of satisfiability admits for
example Sat problems are permutation
invariant in a few ways you can permute
literals you can permute clauses and you
can permute literals within a clause and
you don't want to have a sequence model
have to learn all of this from scratch
it see we can just build it into the
model they're also negation
variant which means that you can negate
every occurrence of any specific
variable also without affecting
satisfiability so we're gonna try to
build these invariances into our neural
network model and the approach is given
a formula like this we're going to
construct an undirected graph with a
node for every literal so there's a node
for x1 not x1 x2 not x2 and a node for
every clause c1 and c2 there's going to
be one type of edge between every
literal and every clause it appears in
so there's an edge between X 1 and C 1
and X 2 and C 1 because C 1 contains
four literals X 1 and X 2 and there's
also a separate type of edge which I
denote with a dotted edge here between a
literal and it's complement so X 2 and
not X 2 are connected by the second edge
right by the dotted edge and X 1 and not
X 1 are connected by that edge now the
basic idea of the model which we call
neuro set is we're going to maintain an
a vector embedding some inscrutable
collection of floating-point numbers at
each node in the graph and we're going
to iterally pass messages along the
edges of the graph so a literal is gonna
pass messages to the clauses it appears
in and it's complement literal clauses
are going to pass messages back to the
literals that occur in them after T time
steps we're gonna map literals into
scalar votes using a learn to network
and then we're just going to average the
votes to compute a single logit that's
gonna guess whether the entire problem
is satisfiable or not now I'm gonna go
into the architecture in great detail in
the next few slides but if you have any
high-level questions I'll take them now
yeah it's I'm gonna discuss survey
propagation a little at the end
cherry propagation does not look like
this the message is the pixel there is
several architectural differences
history propagation the messages that
the clauses sends to the literal depends
on which literal it is like you
marginalize out the other literals but
you can't express in this way but it's
it's structurally similar in the sense
that it's a message passing algorithm
so here's the neuro step model in more
detail where we have a bunch of learned
parameters so two vectors the Elenin and
sein it to initialize the embeddings for
each of the literals and clauses three
multi-layer perceptrons l message c
message and L vote I'll explain all of
these shortly and then to layer norm L
STM's l update and c update now we're
going to initialize a one matrix that
stores all the literal embeddings so
it's two n by d so every row is a
contained the embedding for one of the
literals and we're gonna just initialize
all of the rows to L in it the learned
vector and similarly for clauses every
row of C is going to be the embedding
for one of the clauses and we're gonna
run T iterations of message passing so
every iteration of message passing
consists of two stages stage one
literals are going to pass messages to
the clauses so here all of the literals
have embeddings and they're going to
send them to the clauses that they occur
in the clauses are going to sum the
incoming messages and also get its
previous state with a start of edge and
use the the RNN the the c update layer
norm LS TM to update its own embedding
and here's the matrix notation it's hard
to read but it just says what I what I
just said
you've got the literal embeddings you
apply this learned MLP to compute the
messages one for each literal mmm is
gonna be the binary adjacency matrix so
this is just summing the messages and
sending them to the clauses and then the
clause also get its its previous hidden
state and it calls the update LS TM now
the stage 2 is similar clauses pass
messages to the literals the only
difference here is that the literals get
messages from the clauses it gets its
old state and it also gets a different
kind of message from its complement
because of the extra edges in the graph
intuitively these dotted edges encode
the constraint that they should probably
not be equal yes
what other messages so every node has
some at every time step every node has
some collection of floating-point
numbers that represent something
potentially inscrutable about that node
so at every time step I have some vector
here which represents something
hopefully meaningful about the literal
now that's represented in this matrix L
of T L messages is a learned neural
network that takes those embeddings and
computes some other vector of floats
that represents a message but I have no
Opera re knowledge of what that actually
encodes semantically it has the freedom
to choose what those floats represent I
don't think I said yet we eventually run
it with 128 but it's purely arbitrary if
we had bigger Hardware we'd might have
done okay
suger as big as you can get it's related
to problem size potentially maybe
potentially unclear actually Oh
because reductions having a small
conventional wisdom in machine learning
is used as as bigger vectors you can get
away with in terms of hardware and
performance we also found that it trains
the bigger we made D the faster a
trained but it's not major you can train
these with 16 even with 8-foot yeah yes
although the short answers is back bruh
but I'll explain the signal in a second
so here's the literals and it's similar
I won't go through this in detail it's
identical except for this except for
getting the compliment of the literals
as a separate message it's the same as
the clauses now after T iterations we're
going to compute a scalar vote for each
literal by applying this learned
multi-layer perceptron L vote that map's
each literal embedding into a single
scalar we're going to then average the
votes to get a logit which is just a
single
Gaylor for the entire network and then
we're gonna predicts that as viability
using the logit by just taking the
sigmoid function which is going to
return something between 0 & 1 now the
we train with the cross entropy loss so
we're using back propagation to minimize
the classification error on a training
data set
does that sat as graphs and a single bit
of supervision for each problem
indicating one if it's at zero if it's
unsafe and you use these pairs that you
were mentioning earlier sets all these
pairs Laura says on piece pairs yes
exactly
in particular we don't tell anything
about solutions we're just giving it a
single bit supervision for each problem
let's talk about experiments now so
we're gonna train on SR uniform 10:40
the uniform part is not actually
essential it's just intuitively nice to
use a curriculum here because it's gonna
be harder to induce structure on bigger
problems but we trained things without
the curriculum and it works just as well
and we're gonna know units are uniform
meaning we're sampling the number of
variables from a uniform distribution
between 10 and 40 oh good number of
clauses is determined by how many we can
sample before it gets and we're gonna
test on SR 40 just some perspective on
SR 40 the sporty variables so there are
trillion possible assignments about 200
clauses per problem roughly a thousand
literally occurrences so about five
literals per clause and all of the
clauses are uniformly random so every
literal mistreated symmetrically
including X I and not X I are both
treated symmetrically and every single
problem in the distribution is a single
bit away from flipping between sad and
unset and just a caveat because 40 is
small this is still easy for
state-of-the-art solvers mini-set can
solve SR 40 in an almost negligible
number of milliseconds
and results neurosis that predicts one
85% accuracy we're gonna make that
number a lot better shortly but first
must understand how it even be 50% yes
it's a you Jimmy what you earn here is
for any pair of formulas whether you
have the original and sad or the one
flipped with which becomes sad that's
exactly that's what you're really
learning here well we don't tell correct
we don't tell neuro sad that these two
one is that one is onset they just get
random process from West distribution
yes see so you do this you do when you
feed for the training you do not say
that this one's this one was that that's
that one and this was this a correct we
just feed them be the individual
problems they're labeled but we don't
tell them so you do tell them we don't
tell nervous that you should look at
this pair there's not every single no
it's a sense but what she's effectively
what okay just trying to see why the
nutrition if there is an intuition here
what's your intuition idea in your head
but what is actually being around no
we're good work we have actually a very
good explanation of what's being learned
which I'm going to get to shortly so we
were we were all really surprised by
this number and we trained a few bass
lines including L STM's and we could not
break 50% on any of them we couldn't
train a model that even when you fix the
number of variables and fix the
representation could could even
distinguish on small training sets the
difference between the sad and unset
problems so the best way we actually
bombarded this with experiments and made
no progress until we just visualized
what it was doing and then it became
clear so this is an example run of neuro
set on a problem from SR 20 here this is
the matrix of scalar literal votes at
each time step so this is a 20 by 2
matrix because there's 20 variables so
the eighth row is going to be the scalar
vote for X I and then not X I in the
second column here white is 0 red is
positive and blue
is negative okay so red means Sat white
means unsure blue means
unset now as time goes on there's some
red and blue here from the
initialization which is an artifact of
of the initialization vectors but very
quickly all of the literals start voting
unset with low confidence so light blue
means roughly logit of negative one so
assigning say sixteen percent
probability to stew it being set and you
can see there's a lot happening each
time step
a lot of the dots are changing and
moving around but consistently almost
all of the literals are voting sat with
low confidence we see this on every
problem it runs on and this happens for
a while bunch that with no confidence
quite a few things are happening a few
speckles of very very light red that
don't make any difference because they
get washed out by the averaging but then
all of a sudden there's a very distinct
phase transition all of the literals
start voting sat with extremely high
confidence and the network converges so
these light blues are about negative one
logic these Reds are about plus forty so
this is 99.999999% sure that these
problems are satisfiable and the network
convergence and we see this for every
problem that it runs on if it's unset it
looks like this forever
and if it's sad it either looks like
this for a long time or eventually and
if sometimes usually eventually has this
phase transition where it converges yes
this is when you test what you learned
here yes this is a problem that was not
trained on okay yeah so somehow around
here it becomes extremely confident that
this problem is satisfiable now we
weren't exactly sure what it found that
convinced it but if you look carefully
at the literal votes after convergence
it's a little hard to see because the
resolution is poor but you can maybe
make out a pretty distinct checkerboard
pattern
meaning that there are only roughly two
maybe three shades of red here and for
each variable there's one literal that
is distinctly darker than the other one
so you can you can see a bit pattern
here do you guys all see it roughly you
wouldn't call it what
sorry good so we hypothesized that maybe
this is encoding a satisfying assignment
and that it had become so confident
because it had found it so when
implemented a script to just try to just
read this off and see if it's a
satisfying assignment and it turns out
that it usually is a satisfying
assignment which suggests that the
reason why I became so confident is
actually because it a detected
satisfying assignment and knew that that
indicated that the problem must be
satisfiable now at first I thought maybe
the literals that are true in the
assignment are voting Sat with more
confidence even though I didn't know why
I would do that it turns out that is not
the case
sometimes the literal that is voting
lower those voting Sat with less
confidence is the one that's true in the
solution you try both possibilities so
you try the thing that map's the one
that's that's lower to true everywhere
and then you try the one that's yeah but
but this has turned out to be an
unreliable way to decode the solutions
it turns out that this bit pattern is
just an artifact of the fact that the
higher-dimensional literal embeddings
cluster according to the assignment so
at convergence in the 128 dimensional
space the literals that are true are
going to be in one cluster the literals
that are false are going to be in
another cluster and this bit pattern is
just an artifact of the projection
preserving that clustering most of the
time and ready for this and one
classroom
and not is suppose that you have two
disjoint sets of literals and appear
disjoint the size of clauses then could
you would you learning necessarily
correlate what is light versus dark in
one cluster that's a good question
in that case it is conceivable that you
would end up with four clusters the true
ones for problem one the false ones for
problem one my guess is that we didn't
test that SR forties is fully connected
my guess is that the two clusters for
the two sets of true literals are going
to be closer together and then if you
two cluster you'll still get the right
solution but but the clustering analysis
suggests a much more reliable way to
decode solutions which is just directly
cluster the higher-dimensional
embeddings so here we can watch the two
dimensional PCA projections of the high
dimensional embeddings on a run from sr
40 now i've colored the literal these
are the literal embeddings and i've
colored them according to the solution
that eventually finds so you can see
exactly what it's doing over time these
are just the last nine times steps
leading up to convergence and you see
it's doesn't cluster at all it's all
mixed up it's all mixed up it's sort of
starting to separate here starting to
separate but this is still one literal
is still incorrect and then it pulls
away and then that convergence falls
into two distinct clusters and now this
method of decoding is very reliable and
ninety-six percent of the problems in
the test distribution for which a guess
is sat this simple trick of to
clustering will recover the satisfying
assignment so let's talk about solving
oh yeah yeah so as I said before the
training distribution the satisfiable
problems in the unsatisfiable problems
are statistically identical there's no
way for it to predict that bit
based on superficial properties it
learned that the best way to predict
that bit is to search for satisfying
assignments and not to get sat until it
found one at which point guess that with
extreme confidence and suffer no
objective function cost yes I think it's
a risk it's an artifact of the
distribution not permitting any other
way of explaining the data we're going
to talk about training it on slightly
different distributions later in the
talk and you'll see how the training it
affects the procedure that it learns so
let's talk about solving the rest
sometimes there are satisfiable problems
that for which it does not guess set it
will continue to guess unset with low
confidence here's an example just keeps
wandering around but because neuro set
is inherently iterative we can just run
it for more iterations and see what
happens so we run this run this run this
for a long time fast forward to around
137 we only trained and tested so far on
26 rounds of message passing so this is
five or six times more rounds than it
ever performed during training and all
the liberals are still voting unset with
low confidence few speckles of red and
then around around 150 BAM face
transition extremely confident in Sat
the literal embeddings converged and
once again this bit pattern will usually
encode a satisfying assignment and the
clustering technique is even more
reliable as always now here's a graph
showing the number the percentage of
problems from SR 40 that it solved as a
function of the number of rounds of
message passing so it starves about 70%
at 26 rounds there's what we trained it
on but as we run it for longer it
continues to solve more and more by
about a thousand rounds of message
passing it's solving just about a
hundred percent of the problems in the
test distribution SR forty and this is
solving end to end this is not just
prediction accuracy we are decoding
solutions for almost a hundred percent
of the problems in the test distribution
and curves like this are I think it's
fair to say fairly unprecedented in
machine learning
usually algorithms are not iterative and
even when they are they don't just
continue to
better when you run longer we're gonna
talk about this later
right now no right now it wanders around
forever when training on SR 40 it will
never become confident in unset we're
gonna talk about this later
a few cool experiments now it would be
implausible to solve much bigger or
harder problems with only 26 rounds of
message passing you can imagine that
it's just not possible to reliably solve
big hard problems with so few rounds but
because we can run four more rounds and
it continues to search effectively it's
conceivable that we can actually solve
problems that are harder and so let's
talk about scaling to bigger problems
here this purple line is the same line I
just showed you on the previous graph
and we're plotting the same lines for s
r of n for larger n so SR m-80s are 120
s are 160 and s are 200 and we see
similar curves where for s are 80
instead of 70% it's only able to solve
maybe 40% when you only run it for 26
iterations but as you run it for up to a
thousand it's solving about 90% of the
problems and even s are 200 which is
substantially harder problem and many
sadist now starting to notice if we slow
down on its solving it solves under 5%
of the number of rounds you was trained
on but it gets up to almost 30% when you
run it for a thousand rounds now again
although from a machine learning
perspective the fact that these curves
go up at all when you extrapolate the
number of rounds is interesting and
impressive but it also suggests that the
algorithm as is is highly incomplete it
doesn't look it's possible that this
curve spikes up we didn't run it for
longer but it looks like it's
asymptoting yeah training size how many
of these how many examples do you feed
to your training it's a stream so I
don't actually have the exact number
probably only a few million
but none of the problems are bigger than
this our 40 we're training on SR 10
Brett report yeah so our hypothesis for
Wyatt it flattens out here is that
during training it's essentially
performing some kind of local search and
it never has to restart during training
SR 40 is easy enough that it's
heuristics are essentially complete
without needed without needing to revert
when it gets stuck so when we watch it
run it very quickly makes every step the
first few steps it will flip many many
literals at a time and very quickly
satisfy over 99% of the clauses and then
it'll start taking much more cautious
steps flipping only a few literals and
we see for these longer runs and the big
problems that it just it just stops
being aggressive now we think an
architectural change that would make it
much more reliable when running harder
problems for many iterations is giving
it access to a source of randomness so
it is some way to learn when it's stuck
and when it should inject noise into its
embedding so what we haven't tried this
yet yeah just to see if I understood
what do you mean by the iterations so
you had this recursive relation between
CI and CI plus 1 H and that's the and
these are the transformations that you
buy on the x-axis yes every iteration
here involves the literals passing
messages to the clauses and the clauses
passing messages that's good
so me go back
show you the update seeing
so it's applying a single neural network
here which is as fast as applying that
is in this case it's a three layer
neural network so it's just basically a
couple matrix moles a sparse matrix
multi-domestic passing and then the C
update is another matrix mode so it
depends on the dimension and the number
of literals but it's it's not expensive
yeah the difference is the well so
survey propagation is not learned at all
it's arrived mathematically yeah the the
structure of the messages is different
so as I said before a clause will pass
different messages to the literals that
occur in it here the clause have passed
the same messages to every literal so
there are a couple architectural
differences like that numerically the
very difference of survey prop often
fails for numerical reasons that you're
dividing by zero and here there's
there's no division occasions I don't
know if that's a philosophical
difference but that's a big difference
that there's there's a lot more
floating-point computation being done
per iteration here than in survey
propagation sorry propagation it's it's
a few multiplications and divisions on a
single float for each literal in clause
yeah sure I just do the comment that you
made earlier about the training so for
each of these five here you have
different training sets that you use no
this is all three everything we're
talking about today until the very end
it's just trained on estart Uniform 1040
this is all extrapolation to bigger
problems this has not been retrained so
it's our ten well it's our ten forty
what is that sorry as our uniform 1040
curriculum training on s are somewhere
between 10 and 40 the end is randomly
sampled between
tenant for so 480 for instance so the
training set so basically what's going
on so an a so the under the speaking
patterns that are the other things
intuitively you know patterns that are
learned from smaller instances correct
between 1040 like if you get to 200 try
to detect this pattern somehow correct I
don't think that's the best way to think
of it it's not the way I think about it
I think that there are very few patterns
it's exploiting and it rather than
looking for patterns
it has synthesized a local search
algorithm which is what makes it
generalize we're thus patterns would
what evidence do you have for you our
interpretation so for ice doesn't really
know yeah so I think and ago let me go
back to the video of it in action I
think this is actually this is a
variation of the iteration of the
algorithm it doesn't show necessary a
pattern learn that he's being identified
in a test sample I mean how do you see
I'm not sure I understand the
distinction I think this is rock-solid
evidence that it learns that it needs to
find somehow search for satisfying
assignments and that that is the best
way to explain a supervision bit but how
does it find this so that I can only
speculate pattern recognition so I have
one relevant experiment here trying to
tell whether it was doing local search
or global search it's not clear so we
can decode the solution by doing this
clustering technique at the end it's not
clear that if we if we cluster it's
meaningful before convergence but we we
hypothesize that maybe it is an
inconsistent assignment before
convergence and we tested what what what
property is that part that assignment
had so when we do this we see that the
number of clauses satisfied increase
monotonically very quickly and rarely go
down and we see that the number of
literals that are flipped at each time
step starts out high and as the number
of clauses satisfied goes up the number
of
flipped goes down so qualitatively it
looks a lot like local search some kind
of annealing but it's not clear what
stronger evidence would constitute
because ultimately the algorithm is
inscrutable I can't read the matrices
and understand specifically what it's
doing and we know somehow it's also
getting stuff from the grass on a larger
yeah because it's it appears to be
plateauing
yeah so it's it's not learning enough or
backtracking enough to go search some
other space because it seems like so
it's limited in what its it's gone
somehow yeah because of the sauce and I
think and the the lack of leading to do
or any kind of restart during training
it's just not prepared for such hard
problems yeah are you satisfied do you
have another hypothesis for what it's
doing well another experiment it might
be interesting I just if you were using
just a sequence to sequence based on
strings string encoding apareyam stances
how good can you approximate your result
if there I say we implemented a baseline
and could not be 50% on the
classification times there's two there's
two reasons why I think those approaches
can't get off the ground one is that
there's no obvious way to deliberate I
mean to deliberate to run for a long
time I mean a crucial part of nerves
that is that it's iterative that it can
think longer a single pass over a
sequence is very unlikely to be able to
solve NP hard problems but also it just
has to spend all of its time learning
the invariances that we build in is
another thing there's so many different
combination variances exponential number
of but if you were to normalize the
input for I sense by you sort for each
CROs literals by name and you could get
out of that and still have a string so
that would perhaps help it then have the
tested patent the patent theory serves
me that a simple pattern recognition so
power would be who performance context
maybe I would be very surprised if
somebody could be 50% with something
that
didn't look didn't have this iterative
formulation but I I would be extrude to
be proved wrong about that yeah go to
this you know picking out the patterns
you mentioned you use this as our
distribution because you don't want to
pick up some random yeah we designed it
to try to prevent it from program be
able to explore patterns so did you
actually do the other experiment of
completely running a random randomly
generated you know data so that see what
the like accuracies unfortunately no
we've trained on regular random sat at
the empirical threshold and it does
perform well also but that's almost as
patternless as our distribution because
all of the literals are the same
statistics even though there's not a
single bit separated most of the
problems at the empirical pressure are
going to be so the data set we generate
s our event right is very similar to the
standard uniform random Sat problems the
only difference is that we adjust the
number of clauses specific specifically
for each problem to find the exact
threshold where it big flips from set to
unset but what you can do is you can
just sample for a given n that threshold
is usually at the same number of clauses
roughly 4.27 causes per variable ratio
so if you just sample that number of
clauses for a fixed end you're going to
be a few flips away from flipping my
construction right and we trained on
that and it also has a similar quality
so I mean what I'm trying to say that if
your hypothesis is true then the other
way of you know you know training on
that the other data set should do
significantly better because you can
pick up the parents specifically they
just yeah so I I don't know if the
random set has such patterns close to
threshold well I think one of the
promises of this technique is if there
is a distribution of staff problems that
has special structure that you care
about in practice that this could learn
a unless
Nurik more custom procedure to exploit
the patterns in that dataset yeah but
you have to be careful with the data set
if you can predict satisfiability on the
data set based on superficial patterns
if you have some degenerate data set
where your satisfiable problems come
from planning and your unsatisfiable
problems come from scheduling it could
potentially predict with perfect
accuracy based on patterns without
learning that it needs to search for
satisfying assignment so it wouldn't be
useful ideally you the the usefulness of
the patterns is limited enough that it
has to learn to search but it uses the
patterns to help research better there's
a lot of art in the data set design I
think and we're gonna see nerves that
train on a different data set shortly to
really stress this point that's forward
okay let's talk about generalizing to
other domains so all the test problems
so far have been uniform random which
may have its own statistical
idiosyncrasies or it may just it's just
inherently uninteresting to some extent
there are an incredible diversity of
possible Sat problems almost hard to
conceive how the simple formula ISM can
express such a great variety of
different kinds of problems any problem
in NP can be reduced to set and the
structural and statistical properties
can really vary wildly so a natural
question is does neuro Sat trained on
the random problems generalize to other
domains or is it just exploiting
properties of random set now to test
this we generated a suite of diverse Sat
problems so first we generated random
graphs from a bunch of different random
graph distributions barabási earned us
or any forest fire and a few others
small graphs all of them look roughly
like this about 10 nodes 17 edges for
each graph we generated k coloring
problems k dominating set problems K
clique problems and K cover problems all
for a range of K where we choose K so
that at the hard end under 50% are
satisfiable and at the easy end all of
them are satisfiable and if you look at
this graph yeah I think if I remember
correctly this is a four clique and I
don't think there's a five-click if you
can look at but with at least with pen
and paper and some thought you can solve
all of these problems but they're not
perceptually obvious require a reasoning
and some kind of search even for for
humans but again trivial first at solver
just because of the size and just to
really stress the diversity I want to
show a few visualizations so this is a
visualization of a problem from SR 40
here every red node is a literal the red
edges are between a literal and it's
complement and there's a blue edge
between any pair of literals that appear
in the same Clause so this is a lossy
representation because we're
marginalizing out the clauses you can
see that there's just no structure it's
just a big tangled mess
here's a this beast is a problem from SR
200 you can see again there's no
structure his system an unbelievable
tangled mess now just just a reminder
neuro set gets graphs like this at test
time we're flipping a single edge
changes whether it's sad or unset and
it's able to look at this and compute at
least in 30 percent of the cases whether
it's SATA runs that correctly and
actually return the satisfying
assignment that explains that bit now in
contrast here's a graph coloring problem
which has this crystalline structure
also very few very few edges here's a
quick detection problem where you've got
this special pattern for each of the
five clicks here's a dominating set
problem also has a very distinct
structure that is distinctly non-random
and vertex cover problem also has its
own little distinct flair just to stress
how how different these domains are now
look at the results so in total over the
suite of problems there were almost
5,000 satisfiable problems average
number of clauses is a 532 so about two
and a half times bigger than the biggest
problems seen during training and
neurosis that solves 85% of the
satisfiable problems end to end so again
it's just trained on small random
problems for 26 iterations and now it's
solving and it's finding solutions to
85% of problems that are bigger across a
suite of different domains and in
contrast the percent solved by survey
propagation end-to-end is 0%
so summary propagation just simply
doesn't work on these it usually doesn't
converge or it keeps oscillating between
1 0 and then 0 1 and it's not completely
a fair comparison because survey prop is
not designed to solve problems end to
end it's usually used in decimation
where it just provides a heuristic for
which variables to set but keep this
number here to stress that as far as I
know we don't know
of a message passing algorithm with
qualitatively similar behavior to neuro
set so it hasn't just relearned an
algorithm that we know about it's doing
something new that we don't know how to
explain yeah but for the random problems
oh yeah raisin problems I haven't run it
on s RN but on R and CNF survey prop
will solve a decent fraction private but
fewer than there are some problems is
just it just doesn't work so ironically
survey propagation is derived
mathematically without reference to
random set and doesn't generalize to non
random set problems well nerves that is
actually trained on random set but has
learned something more general that
let's just transfer okay
now talk about yeah it's a hug your
result compared to the classic the old
results about phase transition for
random son in Stansted so our SR of n is
designed to to the phase transition is
only really holds asymptotically as the
number of variables goes to infinity so
for small n like N equals 4t if you find
the empirical threshold which is I think
for N equals 4t somebody like four point
six to fifty percent will be satisfiable
fifty percent will be unsatisfiable you
are not actually going to be one flip
away from one literal flip away from
flipping in general as n goes to
infinity adding a single clause of high
probability will flip you from set to
unset but for smaller and the actual
threshold has higher variance so s our
event is basically just a way of
correcting for that so that every
problem is exactly at its own personal
professional
so for you for saying for small problem
instances the traditional and Cruz
density style kind of thing that one
would use to guess with high accuracy
doesn't work well or is too noisy yeah
this variance about where that threshold
is gonna be the first moment right on
the other hand is there possible
explanation somehow using
like randomized style algorithm
randomized algorithm that could explain
that this that somehow perhaps these
randomly generated problems that you
consider are good easy to solve with
this kind of probabilistic all of you
like equivalent of explaining how the
old phase transition phenomenon occurs
basically something I have empirical
evidence against that which is that as
you would expect as since it's
essentially at the threshold
Laros mini sat will really start to
grind as n gets bigger in fact
because our k's are bigger than 3 on
average about 5 on averages mini-set
will start to grind more than it would
even for a random preset competition we
didn't I I think the current version
trained only the way we've trained it is
unlikely to be able to deal with such
big problems
Oh without additional training just
because these are yeah I've already told
you about all the battles we've run
about yeah okay I think the breath is
strong enough to suggest that it's
generalizing to different kinds of set
problems but uh I don't think it's close
to being useful and big problems yeah
just a quick thing in perhaps but you
your reference to me started I don't
know exactly what it does but it's not a
proof that such an algorithm doesn't
exist that they were randomized arrests
you just I don't know how it's related
entity what I just asked with anyway so
I said is there a randomized algorithm
that could basically explain the why
this class of random programming
instances that you considered is easy or
hard to solve or guess whether it's at
this or not
and then you you answer all these a tool
called me decide the hard hard time
doing it okay
really does why is it relevant I'm not
so familiar with the theory on the
difficult thing of random said in some
sense my understanding and maybe Leo can
correct me is that at least
as n goes to infinity at the the
threshold the problems are thought to be
exponentially difficult now n is small
here so we don't have any specific proof
for n we're not actually sampling at the
threshold we're sampling at this problem
specific threshold but it's believed I
believe that there are if not
theoretical results theoretical
conjecture should be our problem in
general I have no idea what when the
threat what if you're sampling the
number of clauses below the threshold it
is known to be easy
so there are observing propagation with
decimation as you can solve okay thank
you like 99% of the problems with n I
think a hundred thousand if the clause
to variable ratio was just a little bit
under the threshold okay we know those
are easy but we are trying to make these
as hard as possible by sampling and the
threshold for smaller but I don't have
any proof that these are hard and I'm
not relying on it for any of the
takeaways from the Douro set so what is
this special yes so if you have n
variables and your sampling Clause is
uniformly at random let's say with all
causes of three literals in them if the
only sample a couple clauses with high
probability it's probably going to be
satisfiable if you sample a million
clauses with high probability is going
to be unsatisfiable and the point is
that for every number of every fixed
number of variables there's some number
of clauses where there's a 50% chance
that will be satisfiable and a 50%
chance it'll be unsatisfiable and those
are the hard regimes so if there are a
million clauses it's probably gonna be
unset for a simple reason
you're probably sampled just some small
onset core if there's no clauses its
satisfiable for a simple reason anything
you try is gonna be work and it's
difficult right at the threshold but
again this is not particularly relevant
to nervous that or the claims or
takeaways from this project
okay let's talk about detecting
unsatisfiability this is what you asked
about before so neuro sat at least
trained on SR Uniform 1040 is never
confident in unset it searches
indefinitely it searches poorly in
definitely meaning it it stopped taking
big moves and it gets stuck but it
searches indefinitely and it always
guesses low confidence onset until it
finds a solution now detecting sad and
unsaid are very different problems now
proof subsets are just variable
assignments in particular they fit in
neuro sets memory neuro set has a memory
as a couple floats for each literal and
it just needs to represent a bit mask on
those embeddings to be able to encode
the satisfying assignment where as
proofs of unset very so there are some
trivial proofs of ons that so any
formula no matter how big if it has the
clause x1 and the clause not x1 is
unsatisfiable you don't have to look at
the rest of the problem - no it's
unsatisfiable but others require
exponential time or space to establish
unsatisfiability in some proof calculus
where the objects are potentially
unbounded and particular will not fit in
neuro SATs memory so even if it was able
to use some kind of stack data structure
we wouldn't be able to the trivial heed
to code proofs cuz this they won't even
fit in the final embeddings for neuro
set but we hypothesize that if the
unsatisfiable problems in the training
set have short proofs neuro set will
learn to find them and to test this we
generated a data set where like s R of n
the data comes in pairs one sad and one
unset and they differ by negating a
single literal and a single clause but
this time by construction the unset
problems have small unset course and we
do this in a simple way we define this
new distribution SRC and you where you
as an unset core and we saw start with a
small unset core u over a small number
of variables K less than n we're gonna
flip one literal to make it sat we pick
the unset course so that this works we
add clauses as long as it remains that
is viable so until it becomes unset
we flipped the same literal back in the
unset core to reintroduce the unset core
so we have a satisfiable problem here
and then we reintroduced the unset core
by flipping a single literal to
construct the unsatisfiable problem and
we returned the pair before and after
that final flip and we trained neuro sat
on SRC 40 you where you a sample from a
small set a small fixed set of course I
think we used for course pigeonhole to
one pigeon all three to the the Rivest
unset core and and one other and talked
about this so nervous eyes only trained
as a classifier and we're gonna see if
we can decode the course well notice
that the interface doesn't yeah and the
results we get 100% accuracy on the test
set in five minutes training it's a much
easier problem than the first
distribution which you would expect now
let's see how it actually works so
here's a run we call this neuro unset by
the way when we train it on this just to
make just to keep them separate this is
the same kind of visualization we saw
before and the first six rows correspond
to the six variables that are part of
the unset core so this is pp 3
pigeonhole principle three two and you
see that it these are voting unset it
clearly recognizes that those six
variables are worth looking at it does
some kind of computation and eventually
concludes that it's not an unset core
and then all the literals start voting
sat in contrast here's the the same
problem but with the unset core
reintroduced it starts out almost
identically doing some computation on
the six variables involved in the core
and eventually concludes that that
actually is an unset core and all of the
variables in the core vote unns that
with extremely high confidence this is
black this is like negative 100 logic so
this is extremely high confidence and
completely outweighs these plus one plus
twos
so this suggests that it has learned to
at least memorize the unset Coors that
we planted in the data set
yeah therapist yes these are the literal
notes so to select the unset or you have
to yes I'm gonna talk about this right
now so first let's talk about just
recovering the literals that are in the
unset core as you can guess you can just
look at which ones are voting on sat the
most confidence and that is usually
going to consist of exactly the literals
in the unset core but as before a more
reliable approach is to cluster the
literal embeddings at the final time
step and when we do that we see that
this is a problem in SR 100 with a
pigeonhole same pigeonhole principle
core and planted and the hundred and
eighty eight literals that are not in
the core are in their own cluster and
the twelve literals that are part of the
core are in their own cluster and this
this decoding trick works 98% of the
time on the test set SRC forty you but
as as you raise this is not exactly what
you want you actually want the unset
core so you can use this as long as the
number of literals are small you can
still construct a proof efficiently by
just knowing that you should branch on
these first the reason why we don't get
unset cores is that we're using the
literal embeddings are forced to be more
semantic because we're using them to
vote about satisfiability if the
architecture would if we if if we are
aim was to get unto that course we would
predict based on the clauses instead of
the literals and then the clauses would
be more semantic and would cluster but
we don't we don't test this partly
because during training we patched
together problems that have the same
number of variables and different
numbers of clauses so it's just the way
we set things up it was easier to batch
where we only predict from the literals
since the number of clauses change
in principle with a little more clever
system you can predict based on the
clauses or both and then potentially get
the unset core directly but it clearly
has the right semantic information
Cooley knows about the unset core all
right let me summarize the results so
far we train neuro set as a classifier
on random problems for a few dozen
iterations per problem and it works well
as a classifier it learns to solve the
problems on its own in order to explain
the supervision bit and we can almost
always decode a solution when it guesses
set it extrapolates well so we can run
it for more iterations it can solve much
bigger problems not with perfect
reliability but quite often and it can
solve problems from a wide range of
domains lastly it learns different
algorithms depending on the training
data so in the ER in SR 40 where we
don't think there are small and set
cores that learns to search for
satisfying assignments and in SRC 40
where we plant the unset course it
learns to detect them instead of
searching for satisfying assignments now
I want to share what I think are the
main lessons and takeaways from neuro
set first to answer the question I posed
in the beginning yes a neural network
can learn to perform precise logical
reasoning it might not be perfect it
might have some extrapolation errors but
for the most part it's clearly doing it
clearly knows when it is found let's not
just finding assignment and this is a
bit sensitive property it's sensitive to
individual bit flips in the input and so
forth to I think this is the most
interesting part stochastic gradient
descent or back propagation alone can
find such programs without any discrete
search even with very weak supervision
so it's it's almost amazing but the
algorithms the search algorithm emerges
smoothly and gradually from back
propagation there's no moment where it
learns to search the accuracy just
gradually goes up and up during training
and by the end it has synthesized a
search procedure but there's no moment
when it does that
there's no discrete search it's a smooth
process it's it's such an alien
computational model that it's hard to
even imagine but
this is what we found third message
passing architectures are I think
surprisingly powerful and flexible so
the same architecture was generic enough
to learn two very different algorithms
depending on the training data one is a
search procedure and one is a subgraph
detector and in fact we have other
experiments where we train with literal
level supervision and it seems to learn
an entirely different algorithm that's
more like a pattern recognition system
with no phase change no evidence of
detecting satisfying assignments so I
think it's it's a really generic
architecture that can encode many
different kinds of computation and forth
random training data can be useful so
conventional wisdom is that random
training data prevents learning patterns
and that if you train on random data
it's extremely unlikely to generalize to
problems that you care about but we
actually make use of this property we
use random training data to prevent
learning patterns exactly to force it to
learn an algorithm we've forced it to be
more systematic we don't think that
there are enough patterns to exploit in
SR 40 to be able to predict that bit
without being more systematic and we use
this to our advantage and finally I want
to just talk about stat solving in
practice very briefly so modern stat
solvers as most of you know are
extremely well engineered whoops they
can solve problems real world problems
with literally millions of variables
they're really among the technological
marvels of our time in contrast neuro
sat at least as is trained in the regime
that we trained it is vastly less
reliable and efficient and scalable than
state-of-the-art I want to make that
clear however we still have no idea what
neuro set is and is not capable of so we
really only trained on toy scales so far
we trained on small random problems for
a few dozen iterations for a few hours
on a single GPU and conventional wisdom
and machine learning is that scaling
alone can be extremely powerful and it's
a mistake to assume you know an upper
bound on how well your system is going
to do until you really scale it up on
more data and bigger hardware and also
they're all there's a lot of potential
room for improvement in the architecture
itself we talked about giving it a
source of randomness as one
might let it synthesize a much richer
search procedure and lastly the hardware
projections are extremely favorable for
this kind of approach so hardware used
by traditional SAP solvers as you all
know has stagnated and the free lunches
are over in contrast the neural network
hardware Renaissance is just beginning
and one day a descendant of neuro set
might actually be able to beat
state-of-the-art although we have no
evidence of this right now and I don't
think it's anywhere I don't think it's
right around the corner but ten years
out if the hardware improves by a
thousand X I think its attention it's
possible and that's all I have thank you
[Applause]
that's a great question so before we
came up with the unset core experiment
we were trying to get it to do
exhaustive search and we gave it access
to a neural stack and it didn't use it
unless our 40 I don't I think we could
have come up with training data regimes
where it was in its incentive to use it
but sr4 t it's able to explain it by
searching in the number of time steps we
a lot yeah but I think it's a good idea
intuitively it's what it needs to grow
yeah right and in general I mean I think
when you're learning programs I mean
there's a whole you know thought that
well to make the neural net more
comprehensible let's give it some basic
data structures we do understand and
haven't used these but I don't know how
successful is that's been also a control
flow and you know program synthesis sort
of says well let's let's try to do the
machine learning and get a readable
program and I think the algorithm it
learns could not be converted to a
simple reasonable person right right
right most on that's like we don't have
the chance really of extracting distance
right now although there's been some
work on getting decision trees out of
neural
I think this is this project is some
evidence that we might still be under
estimating how how powerful the
algorithm is that it learned the
incomprehensible ones that it learns
like me even without being abstract so
there's also something interesting which
is like you are doing fix point
iteration whereas a lot of the uses of
the trained models are one-shot right
right and and so there's also some
there's also your inherently you know
doing a fixed point but while new
convergence can't but that's also
screwed because tip in a lot of
applications what we just simply don't
have the time right we need to look at
the picture and very quickly classify
there's a pedestrian in the scene right
but here you're working in regime where
you know well it's that small we can
take time we can also just hitter hope I
mean you have a model that's iterable
yes partly that the problems are hard
enough to merit the extra consultation
right there there have been other oh I
see a lot of projects in the last few
years that use a similar message passing
architecture yes but they usually only
run for three or four rounds they're
doing something heuristic not proceed
rule like they're yeah
there are predicting links on social
network graphs or something like that
where it's not clear that the extra
computation helps and Rach they've shown
extrapolation to more rounds improving
performance at all right I think part of
this is Oh going back to the unset core
visualization in neuro unset it does not
make use of more rounds at all if you
run it for one more round it loses this
information it doesn't even converge
it's learned this very precise algorithm
to end up here at the right time yes and
it has no reason to extract to preserve
that information so it's really an
artifact of the training regime
that it was incentivized to to learn
something that would extrapolate to more
rounds and part of the reason is that
these unset cores is the same unset core
each time so it's a it's it's only four
different sub ground detectors and needs
it can time how long it takes
whereas for searching for specifying
assignments it's going to find them at
different iteration numbers so it needs
to learn to preserve that information so
it learns to converge around those even
though it's not trained for more
iterations at least learns convergence
because sometimes it's gonna find it on
iteration five sometimes the direction
fifteen and it's just it's penalize very
heavily for losing cool so if you to
randomness into this in parallel lines
you you might bump up those curves a bit
that you showed for the larger instances
that's I think for us that's our two
hundred we can get a hundred percent
accuracy boom we're not randomization
just having random oh and just training
on test or a hundred or 200 sure sure
sure you're doing the training yeah but
but it but it will be nice to just train
on smaller distances and then maybe just
have some technique to boost yeah so I
don't know how I think the Pyrrhic least
forty is not hard enough to make it nice
to learn something that can do is start
maybe at a hundred it can learn
something really general that would
extrapolate to much bigger problems I
don't think you need to train on exactly
the size are going to test on sure but
you need to try to have something that
is qualitatively in some similar
ballpark of difficulty or at least is
hard enough to require you to learn the
tricks you need to solve the bigger
problem yeah one that one of the things
I really want to stress is just how
sensitive what it learns is to the
training data it will learn essentially
the simplest thing that lets that
predict well on the training data and if
that simple thing is not what you need
to solve the harder problems it will not
solve the harder problems
yeah no were you raising your head
sorry I thought this was yeah how so
yeah so the model and the training
needed generators are all online all
code is here and the archive paper is
there
thank you
[Applause]